all right let's let's start off uh I've
got one which is probably I would say
the the grandfather of ridiculous hoaxes
mhm The moonlanding hoax okay and you
you is it a hoax I thought you believed
it well see I'm just saying the official
title of it I don't believe it's a hoax
you you believe that what you believe
the moonlanding was real sis I got the
receipts don't worry about all right so
the basic conspiracy is that some people
believe or that you believe it some
people AKA more believe that the US
government fake the Apollo moonlanding
in 1969 during the war where why would
they fake it uh well it's
uh let me read let me read my point that
I wrote down no no I'm just refreshing
my own memory uh the government faked
the polo moon landings during the Cold
War to claimed victory in the Space Race
over the Soviet Union with proponents
arguing that anomalies in photos and
videos proved The Landings were staged
on Earth so so you believe that you know
cuz the Russians they were C rushing it
they sent dogs up Russ sending weird
[__] up in space they were like [__]
guys we we we're going to lose this we
got to film some stuff right now get
James Cameron involved actually the the
the the theory was they didn't get James
Cameron they got uh what's what's the
director's name Al no
no 2001 Space odyssey's his name stany
Stan CU that's it I mean look how well
shot it is I would I mean it's it is
Cinematic would have been in it I've
seen every cubic film I sense a little
bit of a similarity did you feel a
similar Direction uh oh yeah right oh
totally totally 2001 took a lot of
inspiration you must have some kind of
evidence to so well for one all right uh
for one very very s uh easy to spot
right in the photos of the moon landing
right have you noticed there are no
stars in the background um um I mean
we're
inace the photographs from the Moon
don't show any stars in the sky isn't
that explained though by look at that
it's pitch black explain that [__] okay
uh that is a backdrop that is a green
screen back there have you ever you ever
been you ever been try to take a picture
in snow it's like really white right
yeah and so it's very it's very
reflective as is the moon surface and so
when when the light is hitting the moon
surface right if you need to get the
camera to expose properly yeah it won't
show up the tiny little dots in the
background Conor I don't know if you've
noticed the Moon is not white uh no but
it's very very gray
Conor you're confusing me with wait
wait hold on a second how camera
exposure Works yes yes if something is
super white and you point the camera at
it and you're trying to make it that
like the bright thing is in a a normal
color aka the surface of the Moon cuz
you know should a bunch of like sun is
just hitting it right it's very bright
so if you need to make it look like a
normal picture you need to like
underexpose the thing so the little dots
in the sky aren't going to show up when
you're taking a picture well okay in in
that that's why that isck that look at
these photos all right look at these
photos have you noticed then how
incredibly well lit they are where is
the light source other than the studio
light the giant
Sun there it have you been outside yeah
the lighting's impeccable sometimes yeah
but you can't you can't see the sun
while the moon is out wait wait wait
that is what do you think they took the
mo when it's when it's it's out what do
you what do you mean by that explain
that it was it was during the night time
clearly and those lights are artificial
studio lights that's why they're so well
lit wait why do you think it's the night
time is that actually on the uh bullet
point L on the bullet point on the
bullet point inconsistencies in the
direction and length of Shadows in the
photographs are cited as evidence of
artificial lighting suggesting that the
scenes were shot on a film set no yeah
wait no no okay no yeah no what do you
mean why you agreeing with him all right
all right all right I'm going to bring
up some something like completely
tangential oh my God what because
Shadows okay Shadows yeah I understand
what they are like my favorite Hedgehog
yeah I I understand what they are
conceptually but like sometimes they're
just [__] weird to me so I I was like
sitting on my I was I was like sitting
on my uh I was I was sitting on my
Terrace the other day MH and I could see
like a shadow with than a shadow mhm
right and I'm like huh okay so I
understand that you know shadows and
darkness is the absence of light yes
right yes uh and I know it's kind of
something to do with photons I mean I
mean [__] lights it's just you just
describe what a shadow okay okay okay I
what you getting at what you getting
where you getting at how the [__] does
light work I don't [__] understand
light all right this light is just
[__] weird to me is it like a
particle or is it a wave or is it both
or is it neither why can like I I don't
understand someone who studied quantum
physics let me tell you okay light is
both a particle and a wave it is called
the particle wave Duality stupid that
that is that is stupid which is
interesting because light is the only
thing that acts like that and scientists
to this day do not know how that works
all right I think they have some
understanding but not quite the full
picture because people used to argue
that oh it's a wave right because he can
pass through a vacuum like in space
right particles cannot pass through in
space right but particles light is also
affected by gravity which waves are not
but particles are yeah it's uh like
light can be light is treated like a
particle which is called photons which
is what Einstein proved but sometimes it
also acts like a wave I feel like we're
spreading so much misinformation already
in like 5 minutes I mean everything I
said
was I don't know when people fact we'll
see if it is like like like bounc is off
something then into your eyes right you
know that right okay that's what's like
the basic concept of like how you would
understand Shadows so what is the shadow
it's the it's the lack of light yeah
it's the lack of light cuz it's more
like if these lights are bright at us
we're blocking some lights so it's going
to be darker behind us right yeah I
don't know why like to me like like in
my mind like Shadow should be like um on
or off thing there is either a shadow or
not I don't like that no you know
there's different levels of Shadows yeah
I know there's different levels but my
mind just doesn't compute that for some
reason like how can that like like a
shadow is a is a is a gradual thing not
like a it's like oh here's where the
shadow starts and the shadow
ends yeah I'm trying to like compute how
that works scientifically in terms of
like how light is modeled I guess and I
never like fully understood that and I
don't know if this this is just like a
me thing I'm getting completely off
topic yeah um isn't it like the antumbra
the penumbra and the Umbra right that's
like the three levels of the Shadows I
don't know music theory J don't talk
that wait wait wait wait wait wait three
there's three levels of Shadows from
lightest to the darkest part of the
shadow shadow that's the ant tombra the
panra and the Umbra yeah I I this is
like this is like something that's
completely [__] new to me it's not
like a harsh cut off right that it's
kind of like dissipates slowly yeah
Umbra panra and antra I was right oh
okay dude well I'm learning something
new every day okay so that's why the
Pokemon is called
Umbreon because it's named after ombra
the
shadow okay this anyway moonlanding
that's what we talking okay so the the
this the question is right there are
inconsistencies in not only how much
light there is but also the direction of
the Shadows yeah okay and another thing
is the flag okay the American flag you
know the day that America claimed the
moon obviously because America is the
rifle owner of the moon right the
American flag appears to flut in photos
and videos from the Moon which should be
impossible since there is no air in the
moon's atmosphere to cause movement
what's causing the movement uh is there
movement I thought I know that the they
put wire in the flag so that's why it's
like upright supposedly yeah but there
is movement it kind of looks like the
flag is like waving around if you look
at some of the footage which I've seen
but that can be explained of just like
you're you're moving the pole which is
still sending a force down to like the
flag part of it yeah also isn't there
also uh I know uh like intense light can
cause like small movements um somehow I
can't remember how I remember seeing
this yeah that's [__] up that's that's
that's that's another property of light
that just like how well cuz it has a lot
of energy right like solar panel right
like how how can you just point like how
can you just like [__] hold a thing
up to the sun you're like oh [__] I can
power my car like you know what I mean
there's a lot of energy uh stored in
there yeah but the fact that you can
just there's kinetic energy that's the
thing what how is that kinetic energy
with light because a particle it has
mass anything with mass that is moving
has kinetic energy light does not have
mass yes it does how is it affected by
gravity can we google this Kai can we
google this does light have mass light
does not have [__] Mass it definitely
does not have mass light has no Mass
thank you very much that's why it's so
[__] up how little we understand about
light it just makes no [__] sense
half of our understanding of the
universe would be solved if we just
understand how light actually [__]
worked but it's all guess work all right
new uh new conspiracy theory light
doesn't
exist it's just something we made up to
answer all the questions that we don't
know the answers of yeah a lot of my
questions with light is just like uh
scientists believe that uh it works this
way and uh it we have to model it this
way because it acts this way and it like
exerts like the fact that light can I
guess exert a force to cause movement
that just does not compete in my head
but there's like a model to show that
that makes sense basically the universe
just doesn't make sense okay here's
here's another piece of info then that
that actually has some scientific
backing to it uh there is a thing called
the Van Allen uh radiation belt right
which is basically this belt uh on the
way between the Moon and the Earth right
that has just like a blast of radiation
to it some claim that astronauts could
not have passed through these belts
without being subjected to lethal doses
of radiation you can't just say like
[__] names and be like radiation and
I'll be like yeah sure go on then uh but
it has a fancy name it's legit I I mean
this thing actually does exist mind you
what is this what is this with this Van
Allen belt what is this van supposedly
it's like this this belt of radiation
that's emitted from space where it
passes through the in between the Earth
and the moon and if you pass through it
it's a shitload of radiation that the
astronuts are going to be subjected to
so how did they survive that what do you
I mean how how much radiation are we
talking about here lethal doses well
what does that mean like can I it means
it can kill you well I mean I some
numbers
here uh what Van Allen radiation belt is
a zone of energetically energetic
charged particles most of which
originate from the solar wind so yeah
basically you're getting a blast of
solar wind radiation
uh so I mean obviously you would get
more radiation than average obviously
people who like fly a lot for example
get on average more doses of radi
uh but you can get you can get pretty
int doses of radiation and well you
might get some side effects later on in
life but you can be okay I I I could
believe it that you would get a higher
dose of radiation and be fine for the
for the journey but I maybe later on in
life you'll you maybe your balls get a
little too big yeah so like go going
through all these points right I like
I'm I'm kind of like susing out I guess
like the origin of conspiracy theories
just in general which is you know
obviously we are not scientific experts
we have like a barebones basic enough
understanding of science uh but when
some of these points are presented I'm
like there's I there was this like line
from like always sun in Philadelphia
which is just like that sounds wrong but
I don't have enough knowledge to prove
you you sure you g me if you give me
like an hour or two and by again it's
kind of it just doesn't sound right I'm
sure there's a scientific explanation
for that I'm just not that guy who can
provide the right counter points all of
these arguments which brings up the kind
of like mental viability to all to a lot
of this stuff which is why is why is the
this like squished yeah what happened
here oh that's yeah that's the light
doing its
work that's Theory yeah that's that's
the
background yeah it bends objects the
[__] is Van Allen I this so like the
shadows and the Shadows and Light
inconsistencies with the direction and
uh length of Shadows um I'm like I'm
sure there is an explanation for it I
can't remember what the exact scientific
explanation for there being multiple
sources of light maybe there was not
just the Sun but also lighting I don't
know if they had lighting from like the
moon uh like the Apollo moon landing
kind of like vehicle as well there could
have been multiple sources of lighting
um no stars in the photos
I wasn't sure what Connor was talking
about when when you were talking about
exposure well look look I'll point a
camera at now right everything else gets
darker so when I point back everything
everything else lights up when I stop
looking at the intense light source yeah
so I was like wondering what you were
talking about when you're talking about
snow I was like there's there's no snow
on the moon no yeah I'm not talking
about snow I'm like have you ever Tred
to take a picture in snow I get it I get
it I get it now I get I get okay I've
saved the best piece of evidence for
last time all right there was a rock
that was photographed on the moon which
appears to have the letter c on it which
suggests that this is a prop that was
used what they marked it with a c why
would
that look at that it says C right there
you see that do you see the C okay but
like how does that prove
anything who's going to the moon and
riding sea on a rock that could happen
naturally says who what who it's too
clean how yeah it's it's C it's way too
clean there's six clean things that
happen in nature all the time I don't
how the [__] you get like that is being
some kind of proof that's ridiculous by
the way I just like to preface I am 100%
joking with all these you're doing a
good job in case in case the sarcasm's
not coming across that's like if we just
saw like a a dick on the moon like
someone like it happened to be a crater
the size of a [__] that Ali trolling bro
must have been a must have been an alien
who likes [__] or a human who likes oh I
mean what I like what I like about this
piece of proof is that it just shows
that it's [__] dumb they clutching
the look at the sea to see guys no aside
from this it's just like how F like it's
fascinating how the human mind can just
pick up patterns and shapes and meaning
and like you know how sometimes you see
like a face or something or like this
this is going to be like the weirdest
thing like just pop into my mind but I
think that was this picture that show
like showed up on Twitter uh semi
recently within like the last few months
which is just like it was a DS case with
like the strap of the DS that was placed
down on a wooden table and it kind of
looked like someone's ass and oh yes I
did see you remember this one and you
were scrolling down and for a brief
second your mind was everyone was like
whoa and you're like oh
wait yeah I totally for a brief second
your mind was just like heyo hey yo what
and then you were like wait a minute how
did I how did I ever see
this I know yeah it's like the the the d
The Bold dad kissing his son and oh
looks like an [__] yeah yeah yeah
there's so many of those um okay so yeah
what oh you what does this have to do
with the moonlanding me f the fact that
you know sometimes sometimes see stuff I
like how you in this Theory talked to me
about [__] van Van Allen radiation
belts you know some scientific concept
you go but there's a sea in the Rock
there's a sea on a rock uh I'm I'm not
really there sold on this one I think
there's a it's a lot of pieces of
whatever evidence that doesn't really
feel very strong and they kind of string
it together to make sense well I I think
what's like the moon landing to me is
like the OG kind of conspiracy theories
I can't think of another conspirac what
I'm trying to understand is like who
started this Theory and for what reason
like if cuz if a bunch of Americans
started this Theory it makes absolutely
no sense it's like we got a dub from the
Soviet Union and you want to like make
it so that we didn't get the dub like I
think I think there's just a group of
people out there that really get
something out of feeling like they're in
the minority and figuring something out
feeling smarter than other people so I
think there a lot of conspiracy theories
come people who like I just don't trust
everything and I think I I know what's
up well I think I think a pattern we're
going to find with a lot of these
conspiracy theories is that a lot of
conspiracy theories from a lack of trust
from an institution you know that's kind
of that's kind of where ad aore why
conspiracy theories especially a lot of
these are formed you get told something
by an institution and people are just
like what if they're lying to us what if
what if I don't trust this institution
you know only alpha males are
anti-establishment
right okay but you know let's let's
let's entertain this thought for a
second okay let's let's let's just
entertain all of these points for a
second what do you have for us you know
I think like some of the one of the
biggest counterpoints M um I've like
aside from like disproving all of these
points right I think about like counter
points which is one of the biggest ones
that has been brought up that I can
think of is just think about the amount
of people that worked on the moon
landing right how big of a
team was working on this one [__]
project and you think that for this many
years people just kept silent and just
said nothing about any kind of Lies any
kind of conspiracy theories and then you
think that you know the [__] script
of Last of Us two could not be developed
without it being leaked or any [__]
big Marvel movie and you're like wait
this is a way bigger event than any of
these other events that have been leaked
put together I like to think all the
conspiracy theorists will say like yeah
but that's because there's a government
operating it and the government is very
good at concealing things think about
how long they were about all the UFO
[__] before they went out with it okay
well well that's another that's when
government is involved it's very easy to
hide [__] away from the public eye that
is a whole another conspiracy theory
you're making a conspiracy theory
there's I believe there's like a formula
there's like a formula for like how many
people would have to be involved to keep
this under like ws and then equally so
the likelihood of like the amount of
people you add in the likelihood of it
being like coming coming out as big
being faked or it was faked would have
been astronomical it would have been so
easy to leak this cuz to do any kind of
filming thing you need so many people on
set or something right you need loads of
people here so that is true um yeah also
you know I think a lot of conspiracy
theories um there is some kind of
unfortunate situations where conspiracy
theories have turned out to be true yeah
and it only makes it even harder to have
discussions people who then believe them
because then they're like w we've had
cons the before I also just like don't
understand why this particular event
because this is such like it doesn't
matter what side of like you know the
political Spectrum you lie on what kind
of beliefs you have what kind of Faith
you have it's like just this event in
the history of humanity is so
significant and is just a W for
humankind that's why people always cons
theories for yeah but it's like why
would you not want to celebrate this
[__] Collective W that is nowadays
incredibly rare I know you have that one
friend when everyone's happy they're
miserable and that's kind of how I see
it yeah but I don't want to be friends
with that person that's you
normally well most people aren't really
friends with conspiracy theorists oh
yeah except except other conspiracy
theist yeah yeah I I I'll give your your
jobble convincing me a 2.5 out of 10 oh
are we doing a r ah yeah okay okay as as
as as a whole you know how would you
rate this one in terms of likeability
liability you know like a two out of 10
yeah I'd say like a two you've got like
one or two points that might throw you
off initially and then you do any kind
of research and you're like I think the
only thing that convinced me was the Van
Allen [__] you don't understand it I
don't understand it so other than that
I'm just like yeah no there's an
explanation for everything the worst
thing is uh because like I've seen
videos on like moonlanding conspiracy
theories and stuff like that so the
worst thing is I've heard of all of
these points before and I've heard of
all the points that debunk pretty much
all of these points I can't remember
them though
remember that's that's fre and that that
just says more about like my own
scientific understanding and how much I
care uh as much as it does that these
points on a surface level can sound
convincing and even if you hear an
explanation for them it totally makes
sense and I just cannot for the life of
me remember them like the Shadows and
Light things that's throwing me off cuz
like I know there is an explanation I've
heard that explanation um but maybe my
memory is just [__] you know yeah I'm
glad I got it right the yeah the camera
wasn't adjusted correctly the scenery to
show the Stars damn straight there you
go all right